we are joined Now by South Carolina
attorney general Alan Wilson who helped
prosecute this case good morning to you
Alan Wilson it's really good to talk to
you this morning
it's great to be with you this morning
thank you so much for having me on
yeah I'm thinking you all are having a
pretty good day Mr Wilson but even you
guys had to be surprised by this by the
speed of this of the return of the
verdict the jury did not ask for any
rereading of testimony they didn't ask
to see any evidence when you heard that
the verdict was in in less than three
hours what did you think
obviously it felt like that was a good
sign for us but honestly at the end of
the day the the quickness in which the
jury returned the verdict of guilty is a
testament to the hard work of the men
and women of law enforcement and the
Attorney General's office and I want to
give them all the credit for a job well
done
do you think Mr Murdoch's decision to
testify to take the stand do you think
that helped her hurt him
um I think it hurt him 100 I think It
ultimately it hurt him in the end you
know this is a person who had spent his
entire career
um it was very successful made millions
of dollars making closing arguments to a
jury and I guess in the back of his mind
he probably believed that this is his
opportunity to make his final closing
argument you know he's been manipulating
people for decades uh lying and
manipulating to get his way and I feel
like he could do this to the jury that's
probably what he was thinking but it
blew up in his face do you find it
ironic that if we hadn't had that tape
if you all hadn't had the tape where you
could hear Mr murdaugh talking in the
background when he said he wasn't on the
scene that the tape came from his son do
you see any irony there that at the end
of the day it was a tape from his son
that really was very damaging against
him
uh absolutely uh you know that tape down
at the Kindle video that famous tape
with the dog tail wagging and you hear
Paul and Maggie and Alex voice in the
background to me that was kind of as one
of our attorneys argued in closing that
was Paul testifying from Beyond the
Grave look my dad was there uh two three
minutes before we were murdered and it
was his way of testifying from beyond
the grave and one thing I do want to say
I've seen I've seen a lot of
documentaries out there a lot of Talking
Heads I know they're making movies and
people are talking about this but at the
end of the day two people were brutally
murdered and gunned down in Cold Blood
and a family was destroyed and a legacy
was ruined and and I just want to remind
people about that that uh you know we
didn't enjoy going through this process
because there were a lot of lives
destroyed by Alec Murdoch and so at the
end of the day I want people to focus on
the lives that were destroyed not as
much about Alec Murdock all right Mr
Wilson thank you very much and again
congratulations to you and your team
thank you so much
Attorney General Wilson we thank you for
your time this morning you can see more
coverage of this verdict on a special
episode of 48 Hours of trial of Alec
murdaugh that's tomorrow night at 10 9
Central right here on CBS and on our
streaming service that's Paramount Plus